all right hello mom my name is Daniel
I'm a partner at Y Combinator and I'm
here today with Qi Liu who's the CEO of
Baidu and is in particular focused on a
lot of their AI strategy so Chi thank
you so much for coming today
you bet thanks for having me cool so I
guess first question that is on my mind
is and I think many others is help us
understand why you'd left your previous
to buy do you were very senior at
Microsoft and a lot of us are wondering
why you decided to leave to Baidu so two
things one is I left a Microsoft purely
for personal reasons because I had an
injury I broke my broken my left hip
so I need a second surgery and need to
take some time off because my job at the
Microsoft or was very critical to the
company I thought it's for the best
interests of a company for me to move on
good great things was that had a good
successor who's extremely capable I'm
super happy that he is taking over and
reading the company's productivity
business moving forward and in
particular also I was able to have a
very good relationship with Microsoft I
continue to serve as the personal
devisor to the CEO Satya Nadella
and also to Bill Gates so when I go back
to Seattle I often go see them mm-hmm
and then how did you decide to go to
Baidu as opposed to any other place yeah
so that's for a simple reason which is
AI plus China because we all know I
guess most people in our field will
agree a is the next big wave I think AI
plus China's is particularly meaningful
because in my views China has a
structural advantage in terms of a
technological development and
commercialization in that context Baidu
offers a
unique opportunity for me first of all
Baidu in many ways is the Google of
China its heritage was search engine and
as a result I was from engineering
capability perspective in a culture
perspective is uniquely positioned to
seize the AI opportunity and also I
happen to be a friend knows Robin Lee
the fountain CEO for almost 20 years so
there's a lot of long-term relationship
and Trust so that was a just a good
opportunity for me to to take off mm-hmm
so in what ways is China's approach to
AI from America's I think first of all I
think it's an environmentally different
and approach wise I'll come back to the
process that's wrong my advantage point
from environmental perspective I think
China has unique structural advantage
for AI technological development and
commercialization of AI technologies for
a simple reason
if I may just explain my thinking on why
this is so because in this wave of
technology development it's there's one
aspect to the fundamental different from
previous generation of big technology
wave which is data plays a essential
role because I offer you this as a
simple example you can have ten thousand
engineers or engineers or you can have
many great engineers you would not be
able to build the system that
understands human conversations you will
not be able to build a system that will
recognize objects or seeing's of images
because you need to have data a simple
analogy is very much like human when you
and I grew up it's not like our parents
or God is writing coding to our brains
our beauty neural engines has the
ability to learn through our sensory
systems essentially our perceptive
systems whether it's visual systems
always as auditory systems that we are
able to observe the world our
observation those sensor these are data
because these data carries knowledge and
we are able to learn from our
interaction with the world as soon as we
grew up we acquire knowledge and same
thing happens for AI technology it's not
about writing code this time it's about
writing code that implements a
algorithms with both soft soft and hard
ways they are able to learn and learn
knowledge from the data so if you take
that perspective data data in my views
for the AI era what becomes a primary
means of production which is by
definition music production is a form of
capital because you look at historically
you know human history let's say in the
agriculture era land is the primary
means of production so that you can see
everything's organized around the land
all the walls are competing for land in
the industry arrows the means of
production is our primary label is an
equipment different type of equipment
and certainly financial capitals human
talent but in the AI era my view is data
will become as a primary means of
production so harnessing data becomes
key hmm and then comes back to China
because China has a different social
economical policy environment that makes
for certain segments not everything for
certain segments it's much easier to
acquire in the Hana state and it was
that it creates an environment for
developing air technologies and then
commercialize those technologies for
towards market oriented applications or
social applications so it is in that
context China has a structural advantage
and then in terms of proach there will
be you know cultural differences even in
entrepreneur world the startups in China
environment they tend to work in their
ways that I would say Silicon Valley in
China you know there's commonalities
there's some different approaches but
that
not the bigger factor in my views it's
the environment that's the more
determinant factors making China to be
relatively compared to other
marketplaces or other regions a better
place for AI development because data
interesting and I guess one question I'm
wondering in particular is in the u.s.
there's this belief that one of the ways
China's somehow doing better when it
comes to technology is that the
government is much more integrated with
companies and their initiatives is that
something that you see it by do as you
guys focus on your different AI
initiatives are you able to work very
closely with the government in general
the Chinese government at this stage has
a lot more willingness to invest in
infrastructure Xing talent and they in
particular see AI as a opportunity for
China to in many ways to ride that big
wave to elevate its innovation capacity
so there was a about somewhere between
one month two months ago there was a
white paper that's published by the
Chinese government it actually spells I
think in pretty much a certain level
details about by 2030 how Qian the
Chinese government planned to
systematically investing infrastructures
talent technologies to enable China to
lead in AI technologies in many
different dimensions so in general the
government is indeed has a lot more
willingness and commitment to to invest
and it was regard to a private company a
particular company I do which is more a
viewed as culture practice ties closer
to American company it's listed in
Nasdaq internal working culture is very
entrepreneur closer to Silicon Valley
style so we do in many ways operate
independently we view essentially market
opportunities as the primary objectives
to pursue those opportunities and the
when there are wing wing alignment
with the government initiative we
welcome that for example Baidu is the
host of a national deep learning labs
and the Baidu is also working with
various different government entities
when they have expressed willingness to
supporting certain areas of air
technology for example let's say for
self-driving cars so we will work with
those government entities to discuss
opportunities that are mutually
beneficial but our prime as a company
our primary means is market success we
don't have sort of any other agendas
because we are a independent company we
want to build products that serves our
users when there's synergix the
opportunity with government support we
will collaborate with government when
they are truly Bennett mutual benefit
mutual win-win
do you think that China will beat the
United States to having mass adoption of
self-driving cars so my belief is the
opportunity to commercialize and deploy
autonomous driving technologies in
various forms China would be channel
will have opportunities get ahead of
United States over the next three to
five years primarily for I would say a
few areas long is different regions
whether it's municipality or provincial
government or central government they
see this as an opportunity for the
China's auto industry to get out of
where
right now the China auto industries
there's no real strong technology heavy
fragmentation with over 20 50 OEMs the
Chinese government very much would like
to take the autonomous driving dimension
of innovations to enable the Chinese
channel auto industry to leapfrog to be
the world's best and reading the water
so so the government is a factor for
example there's five municipal
government right now
members or partners of Baidu's open
autumns driving ecosystem open platform
cada polo so they work who was us a
variety initiative for example a new
kind of driving schools that was
certified autumns vehicles for different
level of manoeuvrability just like a
driving school today they will give they
were certified human drivers in your
pass through certain tests so we're
working on that and working with a new
series B is being kind of a bit of
ground up by the Chinese government plan
will be bigger than Samsung will be
bigger than to buying in an in the 5 to
10 years it's called a chinois
it's a massive new city is being built
up from pretty much zero so working with
them designing new infrastructures new
segment of the cities that makes much
easier for autonomous vehicles to be
deployed just as an example let's say
today's cities you have street lights
and the street lights in many ways is a
sensor device enable the sensors of a
vehicle to be able to better see the
road it just happen to be the one nd
that that does the sensing are human and
humans the eyeballs when when stock you
you won't be able to see the road see
the see the separation of the roads and
you have stewards but imagine in the
future when the sensor is not done by
the human eyeballs right but different
sensor where the slide our radar all
cameras whatever the sensor technology
use the future city infrastructures
those streetlights right will be antenna
for now human sensor capabilities to see
the road to be able to navigate the road
so so we are actively designing those
new type of infrastructures and having
ongoing discussion with these municipal
government to lay out plans to build
those infrastructures with the intent to
have commercial deployment of autonomous
driving in various forms so if you
combine all those efforts
I very much believe in the next three to
five years we'll see
autumns driving in China gets deployed
in more variety in larger skills than
other markets huh
fascinating going back a little bit to
kind of more broadly China in the United
States I'm you were managing very large
software engineering teams here in the
United States and now you're doing the
equivalent in China what are some
cultural differences you've noticed in
terms of how people work how you have to
manage in between those two countries
yeah first of all Baidu's engineering
culture protocol sure is very similar to
Microsoft very similar to what I know of
Google even though I haven't worked at
the Google but I have enough in Russian
with friends who worked at Google
essentially very heavy in technology
very heavy algorithms very heavy in
large-scale Computing's very weak in
product design very weak understand user
needs human needs as a result the
technology is good the product generally
isn't great right just you know I'm not
critical criticizing my former
colleagues but Microsoft has a company
in many ways locked behind companies
such as Apple and Facebook in building
truly mobile particularly mobile
consumer product that trusts the
emotional connections with users and
that was its application or services or
devices the fit in the finish the
experience design is very much more than
appeal to young demographic young
generations Microsoft as a company
struggle on that and I see similar
things from what I can see
Google's company their product that I
use and the parties at the same way
that's one aspects I was try to change
the engineering culture at Microsoft
actually I was the reason why I broke my
leg but it's a different story they
because you need to unlearn learning new
we're doing things can you just tell us
yeah about the bicycle the hero
as I think are you about that injury
yeah because it was a there's something
called a backward the brain bike aha if
you search on YouTube how to ride a
bicycle there's plenty of videos
essentially the back go the other way if
you turn the handle this way do I have
to go the other way that the reason
there's some profoundly important two
reasons because first of all we human
learn there's three primary reason we
lon
this is called experiential learning and
the bicycle writing is the often Sarah's
best example because you cannot learn
how to ride a bicycle by watching other
people riding bicycle about reading
about it by people telling about it you
have to ride a bicycle yourself and
often bumping bruising hurting but guess
what there's one thing once you learned
you never forget it seen the muscle
memory you don't think about it and
that's the problem for large
organization for cultures because the
reason those big companies they couldn't
survive when you wave come that's based
on about professor Rebecca Harrison's
study at the Harvard Business School is
that those mature mental issues they're
muscle memory the way they talk to
customer that they will do research the
day we design experiences was built like
thirty years ago
and they they don't you know think they
try to think about their muscle memory
don't think right so they were just do
think that way so if asking me why
Microsoft couldn't get mobile at all
isn't that we're not working hard we're
working super hard isn't that people are
not smart we tried everything with my
Nokia we build a katana you know you
name it we tried everything but the
product honestly sucks
it's just because the muscle memory so I
I was searching for answer Rebecca
Henderson was the one who convinced him
it this is the real problem so Microsoft
caught even my his name is the bill
Buxton he's one of a kind of people he
said hey Qi you should try this bicycle
thing it was really interesting so we
built the bike blue box they another one
the three of us or try to practice it
because this bike for a normal adult who
knows how to bike takes you about eight
months training every day and once you
know how to ride a bike you won't be
able
right the normal back anymore but you
need to rewire your muscle your brains
and I think for larger one edition
culture change is that difficult because
it's your muscle memory the way you do
things
it just becomes a bit you don't even
think about even though the CEO say
we're not the high you guys have to
figure out mobile you know they tried to
I tried the mobile projects like a PC
Prada smaller phone right because that's
how they had it so we're coming back on
culture
I see Baidu has very similar traits of
Microsoft that I work with so what I'm
working on today was by do is really
change that engineering cultures to be a
lot more product centric to be a lot
more understanding user needs
particularly for mobile product for air
product and then I briefly answer the
the engineering culture between
companies that are in China versus
company during in the in the United
States there are very various different
aspects of it the biggest thing you know
I need to have to think more about
summarizing in my head what I observed
so far some of the key differences in
terms product to engine you know culture
the one thing I would say is stand up
style for me I learned a lot in my eight
months plus living working each other is
the part people in China a lot more
philosophical there are a lot more
reflective they think a lot deeper then
what you would typically observe from a
proud of you
when they describe their product and
also the the Chinese the R&D product
leaders emphasized a lot more self
reflection they call it they use the
word cognition but it means a person's
ability to understand to make judgment
make decisions essentially they've
emphasized a lot more self-improvement
for product people in particular and to
how you elevate your cognitive capacity
so if you ask me the one thing stood out
for me is I used to believe the the
product people in the United States
companies is better than
now I kind of held the other way around
I [ __ ] I see better proud of people more
often in by doing other Chinese company
that in rata was then perhaps I would
say on average the percentage huh also
on that point there's there's another
belief I think in the West that you know
California and Silicon Valley are very
creative environments and they really
allow ideas to come up and bubble up
from any person in an organization
versus China where the image I guess
that we think to ourselves is very
structured society that is very good at
implementing something but maybe not as
good at creative free thought which
would you agree with this sentiment at
all and if so how do you think that
plays out for say doing core research
that involves a lot of creativity yeah
so query a question that that's a goal
so I would say there are different
degree of choose towards the top-down
nature for Chinese company but I do even
though among the Chinese tech company
Baidu is the kind of the closest to in
terms of culture to Silicon Valley a lot
of people their pedigrees are Google
worked at Google or what the mucosal
meaning English is also kind of a common
working language you don't have any
problem if you just you know speak
English or write an email English but
even that the top down phenomenon
happens and my my hypothesis was this is
perhaps due to two thousand plus years
of confusion you know the Confucius is
essentially how many through hierarchy
right so that's the central idea of
Confucianism so having said that the
company died I work with including Baidu
all realize driver innovations is a lot
more about empowering teams empowering
capable leaders to experiment to try new
ideas at the fast velocity paddle does a
lot of those and
in the startups I notice they emphasize
that affects a lot there's no difference
in terms of a belief and practices the
Silicon Valley startups that I see and
the large company one company our
probable point two I believe overall
does a good job is Tencent Tencent they
have this challenging culture any ideas
they encourage the challenged the more
authority of a senior people's and also
for any major initiatives or any areas
of new innovation they tend to have two
teams three teams working on the same
thing huh there's a lot more internal
competitive dynamics that are going on
and the one last thing in PI do we have
this quarterly meeting we have all our
company's directives we have about 200
directors once a quarter we'll invite
speakers and the past few speakers they
all emphasize the aspects of building a
learning organization so that a truly
thrive of an editions each cell each
teams they are able to be nimble adapt
quickly learn so even though there are
this couple thousand years of
Confucianism I think it's still
somewhere they're reflecting different
to different degree in different
companies but buying the knowledge
driving innovation empowering teams
empower leaders are the the common
understanding and everyone addition is
striving to do more and to better in
that regard so so there's no fundamental
difference than Silicon Valley I always
say interesting and and do you think
that Baidu and $0.10 then are kind of
the exception to the rule like is is or
do you guys feel somewhat alien compared
to other Chinese companies which may be
more structured so I would say Amanda
the internet or technology IT technology
relate to the companies even though I
haven't talked to a whole other Mia but
based on what I have seen so far are
largely in the mode that I just
described but when you go out of their
range to go to much more traditional
companies
let's say steel industries or
traditional retails then you will see
more of the the Confucius in
hierarchical stasi management that again
I haven't done studies it's just my
perception I would say this is how I
perceived yeah
so today it feels like in particular
when it comes to a I've research most of
the great research is still being done
here in the United States do you think
that will change over time well we start
to see you know twenty thirty percent of
the papers suddenly be published from
China or well America kind of always be
the hub of AI innovation yeah so this is
the one topic I had a somewhat ongoing
discussion with many of my colleagues in
China our current views the very top end
of research that's fundamentally paving
new ground I would say the example here
would be say deep minded open the eye I
think that won't happen in the next few
years and not won't happening in China
unlikely was that what is it won't say
unlikely to happen the odds of that
happily switch happening in China
perhaps will take quite a few years
right now we see the the research
community particularly the upper echelon
that the gap is closing the leading
Chinese universities the way they many
ways the way the cap is being closed is
a lot of those researchers they are
pedigree they studying top-tier
University in the United States whether
it's you know Stanford Princeton and
they go back so the gap is closing but
the overall environment the culture
context isn't quite there yet meaning
that's complete living by your
imagination the socio-economic is
surrounding is still not quite the same
as United States whereby you have truly
world class people driven by pure
the that these are to seek knowledge the
desire to unleash imagination often
these researchers during the context of
personal fames economic payback once you
have those you you constrain yourself
you you don't see verify you don't go
pursue the the bigger dreams but our
collective belief amount is myself my
bunch of colleagues friends with we all
believe given enough time let's say in
the next five to ten years you will see
top external research work happen in
Chinese institutions and is certainly my
hope that in the next in the summer
between five two years to taneous
windows we will have equivalent of
research organizations let's say open AI
a deep man type that would be truly do
groundbreaking research towards AGI or
different type of initiatives that would
be at the very forefront ears of
extending the scope of humanists invites
it stick time will be do takes time not
in a short short short future yet but it
will happen how are you gonna nurture
that are you are you going to try to
create a Baidu research lab that somehow
has a different culture around it than
what traditional Chinese academia has so
there are several dimensions one is
copper research labs Baidu is doing
quite a bit and our peers whether it's
re Baba or Tencent they are also
investing quite heavy in copper research
labs at the same times the national labs
the top-tier universities they are doing
more and more and there's also in the
private sectors there is always ongoing
discussion a new type of research
entities can be envisioned and it can be
created so there's ongoing set of ideas
being explored I think it likely will be
a combination of copper Research Lab
University and sang-hwa new generation
let's say open air type research
organizations will
we established overtime that would be
capable of carrying top-tier research
work that's based in China hmm
interesting shifting gears to a
completely different topic another thing
that is a hotly debated topic out here
in Silicon Valley is cryptocurrency no
one really knows how to understand
China's approach to cryptocurrency so
what's your take on it yeah so I would
speak from BIOS perspective not
necessary my personal view because I
haven't spent enough time this
particular subject to kind of develop
views that are I thought that would be
educated views I would say is more from
by those company perspective one is we
view blockchain the underlying
technology as a fundamental foundational
capabilities the company needs to have
because Baidu is in the financial
services businesses we have a unit we do
for our financial services and we try to
turn that into a platforms to enable
traditional financial institutions to be
able to modernize their businesses and
we we have a team internally build up a
set of core infrastructure that enable
us to build future generational
financial services using that and at the
same time we are also using blockchain
based technologies to build a new
generation of data platforms because
when I said earlier data would be a
primary means of production and the
ownership provenance value attribution
of data will become increasingly
important so we want to make sure that
we buy do as a company built our
infrastructure to anticipate for that
future of the world we as a company at
this stage do not have active
participation in the cryptocurrency
aspects of the equation with regard to I
want to add one more thing about the
research you mentioned which is in some
ways important I forgot to mention
essentially we now have a view but this
is more of a BIOS
we thought the China as a nation has
been a talent exporter we essentially
send our best people to the United
States some of them come back most of
them we believe China as a kana me as a
market has the opportunity to become a
net not necessarily net but at least top
tier talent importers so in some ways
the the Baidu research lab in Silicon
Valley
seeing tend to be the the the base
station few well to attract truly
world-class researchers to work in Ramat
whereby they have they can have access
to vast amount computing resources data
data assets they may not otherwise
necessarily have access to had they work
in a organization research organization
in the United States so and also in
terms of collaborations we are actually
working with top-tier University with
its MIT Stanford CMU's and the goal I
set for my team is one is we want to
collaborate and the fund some of the
very best two faculty members graduate
students and when PhD students in the
future for those top-tier University
graduate patio needs to be the top five
names or do you think about which
company they want to work for so it's
not necessary Chinese companies research
labs are the my Chinese mmm-hmm the
research labs increasing Engelbert will
be done by global talent and they're
working on problems that's targeted
towards the China market and then has
the opportunity to to globalize it so
can i maybe spend one minute on
typically give you that because I think
it's important lens on how we think
about top-tier researchers the context
is the technology market up to this
point by niraj is something we at the
Microsoft always say it's design for
America tick slightly sell global
industry because United States is the
only mark only country has all those
ingredients talent capital risk capital
technology market
it's the only place this conditions this
combination can it doesn't exist in
Europe doesn't exist in any other
regions but china now has all these not
quite at the top tier not quite as good
as United States but they have all those
ingredients it is my belief the
technology industry would be a for a
while will be a two pillar essentially
driven by the United States and and
portion of the company come from China
so if we view from that perspective the
product that increasingly initially
targeting for China market we have
globalization opportunities increasingly
because this is how we're gonna attract
truly would cause people to work at the
company at like a battle just as an
example let's say for smart homes we
believe the product that's landing in
China market well for small home Prada
was its speakers or new TVs use voice
dialogue based interfaces we have a
better shot of globalized then those
products will be designing United States
for one important reason homes in United
States only works in North America maybe
a little bit of Europe our shadows you
don't have homes like this you have very
spacious different rooms the acoustic
environment far-field
speech recognition wake up or what has
to be five meters along and you optimize
for this but the home in China is lot
closer to a home in Japan a home in
India a home in Brazil so we actually do
have helped have that view
so in Baidu we're building our version
of Alexa our version of echo type of
systems with the larger aspiration of
globalizing those products and because
we believe we are targeting a home
environment
acoustic environment usage environment
that's closer to the to our initial
target market then the United States the
initial target market so I think these
cases will find more more those cases as
we move forward and that's one important
factor
those reading Chinese companies
increasing my views we have the
opportunity or ability to attract
world-class researchers to be part of
what they try to do interesting I wanted
shift gears kind of one last time to a
different collection of topics which is
around management a lot of people
listening to this podcast may be CEOs or
managers and they're trying to figure
out how to manage their first
engineering team so what are some
learnings that I guess you've collected
along your way managing very large teams
at Yahoo Microsoft and now Baidu that
you would give to someone who's just
starting out in engineering management
first of all I would say managing an
engineering team particularly for the
first time you are managing an
engineering team you need to focus on
making sure that the the engineering
foundations particularly build processes
build tools well designed well
engineered well taken care of my
learning of managing engineering teams
is that if you take slacks in those
regard
ultimately what you pay it's like the
boat anchors becomes bigger and the
bigger
anytime you because you will always have
pressure to ship products do the
business get a customers there's always
the temptations to cut corners don't
because you will be far better served
upfront making sure that engineering
foundations are sound that's one
important aspect for first-time managers
manager unity the second is engineers
our says is means to an end
the leader himself or herself and the
team's pay attention to product pay
attention to how the product gets used
understand today's usage scenario usage
patterns anticipate the future usages in
my view is extremely important because
you won't be able to truly build great
engineering systems or engineering a
capable
without grounding those in the product
contest in particular immerse yourself
in truly understanding what the users
are using a product today and how that
usage you will grow in the future so you
can anticipate that's another aspects
the soda related to the today is
understand the business because a lot of
times the engineering work will be
driven by monetization driven by
distributions and these are just as
important as you grow the companies in
business and understanding the business
models how that impacts your product how
that impacts your engineering
capabilities early on and embrace those
challenges up front it may slow you down
in certain aspects but it pays off for
you to take time to understand these and
build those capabilities in and
anticipate the future needs I would say
the last thing is it's just cultivate a
learning iterative experimentation
culture and mindset because it's always
a bit journey you may think at the first
part you figure out I know how to do
this this part of you did it to it this
way but the market is always fluid the
competition is always dynamic setting
yourself you're teeing up for rapid
iterations for quick iterates through
different type of ideas and be able to
seize new opportunities is also very
very important part for a first time
engineering managers to set the team up
for hmm and I guess a related question
is what does qi luo look for in people
when you interview them they panel
different jobs so right now for my
current job the type of people I'm
looking forward to people who really
understand the future mainstream users
usage patterns particularly in-depth
understandings for human needs and also
be able to see through the noise and
understand that the fundamental
undercurrent that driving those human
needs because
think more and more engineering tools
become more mature product developer
methodology become more mature and those
all become table stick what's at the
premium will be those individuals who
are really understands human and they
can't dissipate human needs and I can
envision experience in that context
that's what I think be will be at the
premium for most companies that I can
see and if I look for different type of
jobs even though I may not necessarily
having a product manager but I still
look for aspects my view on this is
product sensitivities that is the center
of every language whether you're sales
person or marketing person and engineers
even HR person if you understand the
product it helps you to do our job
better mm-hmm so kind of understanding
products and predicting future usage
anticipating seeing the future to me
this is a increase in a foundational
strength for any type of leaders mm-hmm
I spoke to some of your earlier
colleagues and Microsoft and almost
everyone said that you were an
incredibly productive person and so I'm
curious to ask you if you were always
that way and if not what are some tips
or tricks you've learned along the way
that have kind of made you what you are
today I I wouldn't say I'm always
productive I tried to be productive and
I think the what helped me was a simple
mindset more of a personal belief which
is a very simple view I view myself as a
piece of software today's version must
be better than yesterday's version
because there's a cliche life is too
short while I lived the same day twice
so and tomorrow's version has to be
better than today's so even though I
make mistakes the mistakes are a
important opportunity to learn so you
can't imagine the Psalter will have more
if statement so that when similar
situation happen you will avoid those so
it's that simple mindset keep the
curiosity keep learning I would again
I am always productive but I always try
to be more productive mmm if someone is
listening to this podcast now and it's
just thinking of somehow getting started
either in the AI world or software
engineering more broadly what would you
recommend they do how should they go
about figuring out what to do where to
apply where to work I would say go to
hacker news / stop
github read a few articles comments and
go to hit github to me get you up get
get your hands dirty
grab some piece of code run a model and
assume you have inspirations ideas
coming to your mind and as you keep
doing this I'm pretty confident you'll
find what you love to do what was there
a point in your career where you
consider doing something else or was it
always clear to you that this was going
to be aircraft I actually yeah along the
way I thought about doing various
different things when I was in China the
in early childhood I always wanted to be
philosopher because I thought that in
order to truly make the solve the woods
a lot of problems we need to have
philosophical underpinnings if the time
was the riveter influenced by studying
comedy communism because it was it
wasn't a quiet study we're required to
study you know what Marxist said that
there's there's the Communist Manifesto
in my vision one of the even though the
theory in my view has has issues but it
was one of the best written manifestos
so I was always in envisioning myself
being a philosopher but along the way
pragmatic constraint led me to the
current path because when I was young I
tried to be a engineers go to a
shipbuilding factory at the time I would
think that was like in the mid or late
seventies building big ships who was the
kind of the most glamorous job so if you
say I work for shipbuilding companies
yeah
kind of wow people but I I wasn't strong
enough because in my years only 3%
people can go to college I wasn't tall
enough I wasn't heavy enough you had to
be like for those type of schools you
need to be over 50 kilograms so and the
way that there is they way you before
you kind of go to the exam so I remember
you know keep eating keep eating every
day waiting just couldn't get to that 50
kilogram so I couldn't couldn't get to
that so I I wasn't qualified for all of
those and then ask around the people say
oh I have eyesight problem I have an ear
sight I couldn't really go to some of
the discipline and then I want to study
and then there are only two choices left
- for me took intimate field of study
mathematics and the computer size and
asked you know my neighbors people for
feedback or a device what should I pick
I people would say if you study
mathematics you can be a kind of a
middle school teacher if you study
computer science maybe you get to look
at the radio Factory so my parents
thought radio factory was better okay
let's take computer science I really had
no idea why once I start to work on this
I truly fell in love I think very very
blessed lucky that I get to work on the
things that I was able to do do you
still code not anymore
so the I read the cold I read because at
coding I gave up quite a while ago
actually it was when I was a yahoo I was
still doing coding when I was SVP I
thought it's important for me to the may
hands off but when was reaching a point
my boss saw at the time he was getting
it immediately you are blocking our
teams I think he was right because if I
don't check in or if I have more bugs
it's actually hurting them more so what
I end up doing is this is actually bring
stone with at the Microsoft will bill up
quite a bit essentially you need to
remain hands on the main shop my
approaches
for the core algorithms I must
understand all the details for the
foundation of systems the architecture
design I want to put myself I can't go
toe to toe was the best architect best
algorithm people to debate with him why
you design that way but coding I thought
that wasn't the productive thing for me
to do anymore so I gave up when I was at
Yahoo at that late stage I actually want
to dig into that a little bit because
it's a question I noticed as well at
Apple which is if the SVP is involved
intimately in the algorithms on the one
hand you're in control of the entire
system is quite good on the other hand
it could be seen as kind of
micromanagement you're not giving an
opportunity for the directors and the
managers to grow so did you ever get
that feedback yeah and how are the times
yeah this is to me it's it can be
managed properly because I view my role
is not to make decisions
my role is to challenge you so I always
say why I have to design this way no I
want you to give me a perfect solution
because I know algorithm can be this way
but also always medically it's your
decision to make but I see you have
hosing or thinking I want to challenge
you I want to debate with you so I kind
of ask build how do you keep up what's
your approach he essentially the same
approach if he knows Excel codebase
extremely probably better than anybody
else and yes yeah yeah so you're like it
was some time we have I'll be like it
she trusted me I know the color better
than you like I know I got that but I
the and then you also surround yourself
with a bunch of technical senior
technical talent that they all are
superbly each of domains you have
ongoing dialogues this is how you
essentially keep your mentor a very
sharp but the decision-making to me is
managing California I think it's very as
a principle you want to make sure that
you are chief scientist gets to make
algorithmic decisions for me like a
young person now here's a turtle here
and I have debate argument for I don't
know cojones are so many
fundamental issues but always medically
yeah and you make the decisions but I
think you're wrong here just so Google
is the owner of the way with you
so I participate on a lot of those to
keep myself grounded in my thinking's
understand the lower level detail of the
algorithm the key algorithms whether
it's in rankings or content quality or
those and then on key systems the
underlying systems low-level fabric I
thought that it's very important to
understand those and you pick a few more
of a pillar types so that your high
level understanding can alway go to the
physical layers and that helps to
calibrate other different type of
systems right you have something to
anchor your thor's and then in
management maybe I say one more thing
this is a great way to not people
[ __ ] you boo should it happen all
the time if you do a few times they know
you can't [ __ ] this guy because he's
gonna challenge you so otherwise you
know people will cook up beautiful
stories try to you know [ __ ] right
so because it's a larger one of the
issues everybody wants to be promoted
not just for anybody intent but
sugar-coating yeah exaggeration happens
all the time if you yourself are
grounded in core technologies it helps
to set the tone right when we talk about
technology that's have honest debate
sharp contrast debate but make it clear
the the leaders are in charge make a
decision you need to pick a few key
technologies that you actually have full
stack knowledge of but don't try to have
that knowledge for every single part of
the organism I think it's impossible
I used to then you break you know tell
us of a management had to tell you of my
practice Yahoo I was able to largely do
this essentially my requirement for
myself is I can do the jobs to level
down for the moment what are the reasons
because I can tell whether my guy gets
[ __ ] or not right because I can
often tell you dude you got [ __ ]
about your guys because I talk to them I
know what they do because I do that a
few times you know you set a to do you
work super hard they make sure that I
don't spoil them they got [ __ ] right
so it's really kind of anchors the
engineering munitions
is doing the best to work everybody's
honesty in that communication nobody
tried to push it your boss so I insist I
would do be able to do the jobs to level
down so I always do that
but at some point it's just too much
just just physically impossible then you
pick a few key to meet I call my mental
mother there's a left right hand after
particularly for Product Search
essentially algorithm and system
architecture play equally important role
get the core set of algorithms I studied
everything essentially yeah all the
details are study and debate discuss who
is the best people and then core systems
whether its content systems serving
systems from all that or whatever all
the way up just to pick those and then
you can calibrate all other systems you
can just see all this that system
similar to this I don't need to
understand detail but I can extrapolate
on how that system works that's a very
interesting rule so be able to do the
job to levels down now something that I
think will be on the mind of any CEO
listening to this does that apply to
Satya that is to say do you anticipate
Sachi being able to do your job and
people that report to use job Sachi used
to report to me for two years we kind of
talked talked about it we all understand
there's there's there's a spirit of that
approach and there is also limitation on
what you can physically do but if you
can find ways that works for you but
achieve the same effect meaning the fact
is each leaders you are granted our
technological and the the real
underpinning of technology you don't
build your strategy based on shadow
unsupported understanding of technology
that to me is important our industry is
driven by technology and there's many
different ways to do that different
people may have different approach as
long as you achieve that as long as you
set the tone for any sort of discussions
nobody should [ __ ] on things you
don't exaggerate you don't have to get
extra credit you don't deserve you
honestly talk about your technology
honors they talk about you are
protocols as long as it achieve that I
think because it's the outcome versus
the the approach for me I used to do
that because and where the Yahoo is is
kind of easy for me to do i i was when i
leaving yahoo i had all in addition
about 3,000 people i thought that i
pretty much know all of them hired a lot
of them work who is a lot of them so you
kind of get used to it say okay tell me
you know
show me your code let's look at the
system how you do that things but in
microsoft it's it's a different setting
I don't think you necessarily have to
follow that approach as long as the the
goal is achieved each senior executives
making or decisions based on grounded
understanding of the underpinning
technology and its trajectory
what's drive those technology forward
and then organizationally there is a
truthful honest conversations mm-hmm
if there's a side to error on too much
or too little rope it seems like you die
on the side of too little rope that is
to say if you can micromanage or be too
distant would you err err on the side of
micromanaging almost no let me say this
it's a evolving journey for me if you
ask me today our eye on the side of
giving more for some important reasons
it's my learning particularly more
recent working in China increase anyone
I come to realize to is each company
there's an overall operating output
capacity the capacity is really driven
by the readers understanding and the
learning capabilities and the structures
they set up to enable unleash more
independent points of views independent
learnings to pursue for the same
objective which is the company's
overarching vision and the mission if
you overly constraint to say there's
some degree
of degree is a tight hot harmony along
certain dimensions you tend to overly
constrain the collective imagination
creativity capacities or the nation's so
therefore I'm more more in the mission
of designing or nourishing structures
and meta models and that enable a
organizations have more leaders senior
leaders that is able to exercise
different way of thinking different lens
are looking at the same problems and be
able to pursue an experiment when we are
trying to solve a larger problem sort of
a larger missions in the past
I'm was more on the operating more of a
super tight ship
ensure everything falls in line but out
of my own learnings at this stage I see
a lot more good by having one edition
that gives more ropes to our leaders
give them more autonomy give them more
independence but somehow orchestrate the
entire dev in a way that the effort or
add up towards a common mission common
goals that to me is a important request
but I'm already lean towards a giving
more ropes so I guess you just have to
be very careful with those leaders to
make sure that they themselves are not
giving too much rope and so forth and so
forth yes you need to design a meta
structure and just in that context
motivation is very very important
understand the human motivation become a
key part of designing that meta
structure and I think what Reed Hoffman
is book Alliance actually is one of the
simple but effective model essentially
you have three different type of tour
duties and particularly for senior ones
are you really foundational let's say
we're going to go all the way into the
end we're so aligned our share the goals
or you are much more of a
transformational you just want to get
something into your belt so you can move
on that phase
not as you are very clear and then you
know the you are senior leaders or your
important position each people they're
motivated riven by what because
motivation is very important the
capacity motivation in a structure that
ties these things loosely tie these
things together to me is perhaps a tea
again we use the word at the premier of
company design organization designs that
enables a original founding teams or new
management teams to initiate a lot more
innovation capacities as someone who's
very philosophical but it also has an
engineering mindset how do you kind of
marry both of those worlds to live by
specific rules the answer I will give
you is when I joined the Microsoft Steve
Ballmer asked me to my first speeches
give a self-introduction about myself
what I live for
how to do my workers so I said should I
wrote simple set of slides I think I
mentioned five things these are not as
Susur rules but I think largely I think
will answer your questions essentially
first learn everyday why did this talk
about I view myself as a piece of
software don't live the same day twice
the second is integrity to me integrity
has three subsets one is always speak
truthfully you will now hear me say the
same thing differently when I talk to
different people always said I may be
wrong but I would say the way I see it
that that's one aspect the integrity the
others keep my would if I give you my
word I will do everything I can to give
my word to me is very important a third
part of integrity is acknowledging my
mistake or weakness to me as a leader
this is important the part of of have
high integrity because we're going to
make mistakes the leadership public
acknowledge the mistake you made or your
weaknesses so that's integrity and being
frugal always to me a penny earned is a
penny saved is same as a penny earned
there's always a rainy day when can you
when you can save financial resources
always save because there's always
better way to use those resources so
being frugal to me is always important
to part of what I do let me see there's
there's five things integrity learn
every day or work ethics I always say
for me personally I would do something I
would do a work only if this work I
thought I love you so much
I would be all you as soon as you leave
nothing behind every ounce of energy
it's all in there so that's work ethics
are also when I say well caustic is
always make it clear that people in Maui
you don't have to follow what I do so
because having a balance to work-life
balance is always good thing for but for
me I always be only I forgot there's one
more thing there's one more thing ice
it's it's too
I remember those five things I said give
me the minute I may be able to remember
but this is what I share with my teams
when I initially joined Microsoft to say
Who I am
how do my work those you can consider
those our rules but this is these are
the the fundamental set of beliefs that
guides what I do feel like that's a very
good note to close on chi thank you so
much for spending the time with us today
you bet thanks for having me real
pleasure
you